hello everyone my name is Zach Holden
brand I'm with zebb therapeutics and
it's a tremendous honor to be with you
today to talk a little bit about the
science of hemp all of us have probably
heard a little bit about CBD and
considering its ubiquitous all over the
place you can find it at gas stations
and grocery stores but unfortunately not
much is known about the science of it
how its characterized and and how the
plant that it's derived from is
characterized so I'm gonna touch on on a
little bit of that today and of course
be available for any questions that you
may have so right off the top basically
cannabis and ham are synonymous they are
if they are derived from the same plant
the only difference between the two is
that cannabis or marijuana which the
people regard as somewhat of a
derogatory term is rich in the molecule
THC which is known as the psychoactive
compound whereas it's hemp which whereas
the hemp analog is is relatively devoid
of THC and is more rich in CBD now when
we're talking about cannabis
there's really a dichotomy if you will
into the two different subspecies one of
which is cannabis indica and one of
which is cannabis sativa
there's also a third species known as
cannabis ruderalis more or less known as
a fiber type plant but for the most part
everyone looks at cannabis and hemp in
in the context of indica and sativa now
unfortunately this has been grossly over
simple I over generalize if you will in
terms of people's characterization of
this plant most people look at a
cannabis indica varietal as something
that you would take as an analgesic
something that's going to relax you
maybe as a sleep aid versus a cannabis
sativa species or varietal that would be
more invigorating would trigger
creativity energy production
unfortunately it's just not that simple
and
what I advise folks in this space is
that you really need to get plants
comprehensively characterized in order
to know what the designated use for that
medicine is you certainly can't just
take someone's recommendation that this
is a an indica or a sativa strain or you
certainly can't go off someone's
recollection of the nomenclature in
terms of its name to really know what
that plant should be used for a desired
outcome because there's everyone names
their plants differently there's just
really no way to know based on someone's
recollection you really just need to get
the plan tested and go based off of the
analytical data so that's what we're
gonna talk about today so where is the
medicine and one of the most frequently
asked questions that I get is how can a
hemp varietal have upwards of 25% CBD in
the case of some of the cultivars I'm
going to show you today how can a plant
have 25% of its weight in only one
molecule how is that even remotely
possible to the active count for water
you have to account for vegetative
matter cellulose lipids fats and the
truth of matter is is that this plant
has what's called trichomes which are
these extracellular glands if you will
these little glass balls on the other
side of the leaf matter that are
incredibly rich in the cannabinoids and
the terpene molecules and so basically
how this plant is able to be so rich in
cannabinoids and chirpings is predicated
on the density of these little glass
balls so talked on the the cannabinoids
we're probably all familiar with the
major two constituents which is THC
tetrahydrocannabinol which is best known
as the psychoactive compound known for
giving you the quote-unquote high it's
also very powerful anti-inflammatory
analgesic neural protectant it's been
shown to provide value in diabetic
patients by reducing intraocular
pressure that's associated with glaucoma
and
it can affect specificity and muscle
tension we're certainly as I alluded to
in the CBD era with it being ubiquitous
all across you know the United States
Canada and then certainly reaching out
into international markets CBD is best
known for modulating the THC induce
psychoactivity so the two molecules
actually act on the same receptor and
anyone that has had too much THC for
example that experience can be modulated
or even attenuated by the ingestion of
CBD CBD is also known as an NG
tumorigenic compound in EURion studies
and is probably most famously known as
an anticonvulsant some of the best
anecdotes that I can give or a patient
that my colleagues and I are working for
working with by the name of Lenny young
who is a beautiful young girl who was
suffering with epileptic seizures
upwards of hundreds of these a day
completely debilitating and since taking
a CBD rich medicine that's been prepared
by my colleague Adam Jaco and talk about
here a little bit her seizures are down
to a handful a year so it's truly a
revolutionary medicine for children with
epileptic seizures and fortunately
across the United States there are some
favorable legislative changes that are
allowing states that aren't favorable to
cannabis and or hemp for these children
to get CBD based medicines CBN is a
powerful appetite stimulant so for
example anyone that's undergoing
chemotherapy or an antiviral therapy you
know generally those folks are
struggling with with poor appetite and
so of course you've got the CBN molecule
that could help them with that it's a
powerful analgesic it's also an auntie
tumorigenic against some forms of lung
cancer and this has also been shown to
be a powerful sleep aid CVC cannabic
Romijn is an antibacterial and
antifungal agent also a powerful
anti-inflammatory keep in mind this the
aspect of reducing inflammation is a
major focal point in cannabis and it's
pretty much it's covered by a number of
different molecules as you'll see as we
go through this presentation it's also
been shown treats of depression and
stimulates nerve and bone growth so for
example based on this data alone my
colleagues and I said therapeutics are
interested in growing out high CBC
genetics for the pre-emptive treatment
of a neurodegenerative diseases so again
as as I'm going through all these as
you'll see there's a little bit of
something for everyone in cannabis and I
would more or less equate this to when
opium first came out in the early 1900s
there were hundreds of natural products
that needed to be characterized some of
which are now the basis of the medicine
that we use today
CBG this is known as the progenitor
molecule which gives rise to a number of
other constituents in the planet it's
effective in treating inflammatory bowel
disease a potent antibacterial agent and
enta tumorigenic against prostate oral
cancers THC v which has a very similar
name and similar structure to THC is not
a psychoactive compound but it is an
energy and metabolic stimulant and it
has been shown to increase fat
metabolism and the beta oxidation of
lipids in mice it's also been shown to
improve glucose intolerance and it is a
powerful anti-inflammatory ninja
convulsant and lastly is CBD be much
like CBD is a powerful anticonvulsant
agent so to really understand the
beautiful thing of cannabis and ham and
the versatility of these plants is is
best illustrated by you know this
schematic of cannabinoid biogenesis as I
alluded to previously
CBG or in this case CBG a cannabic
Uralic acid is known as this progenitor
molecule and what we find is that this
individual compound can then be
differentiated into THC a CB da and CVC
as we move from left to right just on
the basis of enzymes so that we have th
see a Cynthia CBD a synthase CBCA
synthase so again we've got one molecule
that's now given rip rise to three other
molecules now if we treat those
carboxylic acids with heat and induce
decarboxylate decarboxylation now we
transform those three compounds into
Delta 9 THC CBD and CBC all of which you
know again we started with one molecule
and now we've given rise to six others
furthermore if THC in indoors oxidation
now you've formed CB n similarly if you
exposed CBC to UV exposure now you've
produced CBL so on the basis of
enzymatic reactions the addition of heat
oxidation and the exposure to UV
radiation you have now taken one
compound and produced eight others so I
mean really quite phenomenal and so
people are now obviously trying to
exploit this biogenesis pathway to
increase the yield of these individual
molecules so they can make selective
medicines for individual conditions and
as amazing as the cannabinoids are they
really only tell part of the story and
what I'm referring to here is the
inclusion of the of the terpenes and
what we're referring to in the industry
as the entourage with the synergistic
effect and what we found is that you
know the terpenes on their own are very
powerful molecules but their efficacy is
greatly enhanced by the inclusion of
these disturbing molecules and it's
really a synergistic effect where one
plus one equals three so terpenes are
very unique and fairly ubiquitous class
of hydrocarbons they're found in the
natural world all over the place there's
tens of thousands of these and these are
these are found in hot
in case of my Racine they're found in
pine needles in the case of beta and
alpha and beta piney and in the case of
my guest bathroom they're found in the
form of flannel all if anyone has a
lavender scented candle
so these terpene molecules have
different sorts of structures they're in
the form of aldehydes ethers carboxylic
acids ketones and they have you know
various functions that they play in the
body the beautiful thing of again hamp
here is that it's more or less a fruit
salad if you will of these turkey
molecules so for example if you wanted
to get the therapeutic benefit of all
these individual constituents some of
which I just mentioned you know you have
to have a pretty extensive you know
schedule to your day so for example if
you wanted to get piney carry off lean
carving limonene and lentil all all of
these turkeys here you know let's just
kind of go through a simulated day here
I mean you'd have to walk through a pine
forest to get your pine mean isomers you
know then you'd have to have a well
peppered steak to get your carry off
lean and then you're gonna go through a
cedar pouch to get your carrying or
perhaps you're gonna have rosemary on
that state as well then you're gonna
have to with your steak you're gonna
have a lemonade so you can get your
lemonade and then you're gonna go into
your guest bathroom to absorb that or in
just that lentil all from the lavender
scented candle and then we've got more
citrus which you're gonna get your
terminals and then maybe you get for
dinner you have a you know a Thai dish
with lemongrass so you can get your
narrow and then you accompany that with
a beer to get your humulin and then
maybe a glass of wine to get your
geranyl and the with all that being said
it's a pretty extensive process to get
all of those therapeutic elements
whereas one can just enjoy cannabis and
or him because it is so rich and diverse
in those molecules and as I alluded to
before I mean these are very very
powerful anti-inflammatory agents based
on their chemical structures here
of witcher polycyclic they fit very
nicely into a number of different
receptors in the inflammation pathway
and again we're looking at cannabis and
hemp having upwards of a hundred
different turkey molecules of various
structures so inflammation is obviously
very nice but it's only part of the
story these terpene molecules also have
other tricks and all their value that
they can provide in the therapeutic
context and one of which is actually
antimicrobial activity so interestingly
the closest genetic relative to him
actually is hops and if we look at the
story of how IPAs or India Pale Ales
were procured it wasn't for the same for
having something that was incredibly
bitter that only a select few liked to
enjoy
actually it was a way to purify water so
as as folks were going on these long
voyages and the quality of their water
was questionable at best basically they
found that if we boil this water with
some grains and we add these hot flours
to this it's going to help purify the
water and that's because the terpenes
are powerful antimicrobial agents so if
we go down the list of some of the most
prominent terpenes that you're gonna
find in hemp and cannabis in addition to
the antimicrob are they and the
anti-inflammatory activity we see a lot
of activity against parasites and
against fungi and against bacteria which
is which again is quite remarkable so
that's why folks are using hemp drive
oils and concentrates against any kind
of bacterial related conditions such as
acne for example dandruff is attributed
to the propagation of certain strains of
our species of fungi and so there you
could essentially create a hemming
basting dandruff shampoo so again this
plant is incredibly diverse with natural
products that need to be harvested and
Exploited for the treatment of various
conditions and so again I I've touched
on on the expression of some of these
molecules
now I'm gonna touch on on some of you
know the analyses for these things so in
addition to the cannabinoids and here we
have some some pictures of some of the
hemp that you know we're growing at our
R&D facility at said therapeutics you
know which is incredibly rich in in CBD
and some of the other ancillary
components one also needs to use a
number of other analytical tools to
characterize this product for with
respect to safety so it is a natural
product whether you're growing it
indoors and in greenhouse or you're
growing it outdoors so it is going to be
exposed to the elements and as a result
of that it can be exposed to pests it
can be exposed to mold mildew and
bacteria now again the plant naturally
fights against those elements with the
expression of its terpenes but for in
the case of our RNA facility in southern
oregon we've been blessed with a very
unfavorable and wet summer where you
know mildew has been a prominent issue
for everyone and so in order to create a
hemp based medicine you need to know of
any of those microbial elements are
still remaining in your products so in
addition to using high-performance
liquid chromatography to characterize
the cannabinoids and using gas
chromatography to characterize the
terpene elements one also needs to
characterize prominent bacterial and
fungal elements this can be done done
with MALDI TOF ms this could also be
done with quantitative PCR or even a
simple aerobic plate count additionally
these plants are incredibly effective at
a process called fight over mediation
which means they will absorb metals and
minerals in the soil very effectively so
this is both a great thing from an
environmental perspective because okay
you could grow this this plant in a
contaminated area let's say like a
Superfund site and it could really
remediates oil on the other side of that
sword for example if you are using poor
quality water to water these plants
let's say in Arizona people growing
outdoors the water is incredibly rich in
arsenic and also with scaling elements
obviously you wouldn't want high levels
of arsenic in your hand products that
you're looking to use as a medicine and
so that's where the the icp-ms or
icp-oes people are using to characterize
what are referred to as the Four
Horsemen in this particular space which
would be arsenic cadmium lead and
Mercury again depending on the quality
of the water that is hitting these
plants and the quality of your soil that
you're growing them in if you have high
levels of these metals and that that
plan is going to uptake those metals and
it's going to be highly concentrated in
the plant material so again in addition
to characterizing the medicinal elements
such as the cannabinoids and the
terpenes it's just as important to be
characterizing the potential microbial
elements assessing and the potential
heavy metals and in the case of folks
that are using some kind of bacterial
side or herbicide you know these
elements are certainly frowned upon in
the industry but when people have now
millions of dollars at stake with crops
and they're they're in fraught with high
levels of mold and mildew and moisture
in the area you know they may result to
using some of these these false organic
compounds to treat the plant and so
that's where you would be using a
combination of of lcms triple quad or
GCMs triple quad to be characterizing
those volatile and semi-volatile
pesticides so as I touched on there a
little bit I mean and most of the the
data that I can show you here today is
on the HPLC front you know we're
fortunate enough at our facility that we
have our own HPLC we're characterizing
plants at the various stages of their
lifecycle and our interest in addition
to producing high levels of CBD is to be
focusing on some of the other ancillary
components so CBD is nice but it's only
one
sermon in the orchestra and here we have
a picture kind of a character caricature
of my colleague Adam Jacque who most
people would regard as somewhat of the
George Washington of the CBD space he's
been working in this space for 20-plus
years and really a phenomenal guy in
that he's had families from all across
the United States come visit him in his
home in Eugene Oregon where he provides
them with free medicine and helps these
kids and he's helped hundreds of
families and it's really quite inspiring
to see him do this work so my job is
that as a technical guy is to more or
less Shepherd him to increase the
expression of some of these other
elements so that we can then make novel
medicines for other folks that may be
struggling with other conditions other
than just let's say cancer or
neurodegenerative diseases or
neurological disorders so as I touched
on we've got the acidic forms these are
the carboxylic acids we've got CBG a cbc
a CBL a CBGB AC th cv a cDNA and CBD VA
and i know that's a mouthful when these
are treated with heat then it undergoes
the decarboxylation reaction and then
you get the neutral forms which are CB g
CB c CB l CB g v th t v CB m and CBD b
respectively in addition to that we have
other metabolites such as CB e CB CT
that are produced by the exposure to
things like light such as CL CBL is
converted from cbc from the you know the
treatment of UV radiation there are
other metabolites but should be told
there are hundreds of cannabinoids that
have been characterized in the
literature before and your simple HPLC
probably just isn't sensitive to detect
the the you know kind of infant is mole
amounts of expression that you'll see in
these plants albeit you know we're
fortunate to be working with tramonto on
this and their instruments are
incredibly powerful we believe that
we're getting the greatest sensitivity
that we possibly can so in addition to
these these cannabinoids here I'm going
to show you a couple of quick
chromatograms here of some interesting
plants that we've produced most recently
you saw the pictures in the pie graphs
of the high CBD genetics we've also been
working on a high CBC genetics in this
case this top chromatogram here shows
you know your various cannabinoids being
detected but it shows that approximately
50% of the peak area here or you've got
basically a 1 to 1 ratio of CBD to CBC
so this CVC plus sample this is a strain
that we're looking to develop again for
neurological disorders and
neurodegenerative conditions in addition
to that we've been formulating a strain
which is referred to as cattail great
and so what's interesting about cannabis
is in hemp for that matter is that we
have what's called ex-59 which grows in
a single stock formation you can grow
hundreds of thousands of these plants
per acre the problem with it is if these
plants are have been historically
harvest for fiber
they've been historically harvested for
the hemp nuts which would go under
oatmeal and they've just recently been
found that they have you know residual
amount of CBD which is about one to
three percent bike on contrary you've
got your no other hemp genetics which
i've shown you previously which grow
like Christmas trees so instead of
having quarter million single stocks in
the field
you've got approximately 2,000 plants
per acre and these are gonna produce in
the case of ours up to 25 percent and in
the case of ex-59 again you you you're
probably harvesting a couple thousand
pounds per acre but again it's it's the
two percent yield where as you grow this
these Christmas trees in most cases
cherry wine is the most synonymous
genetic out there which grows in this
type of morphology you're gonna get a
product that has about 15 percent so
it's a much greater yield to grow
your plants the problem with that is
that the growing like Christmas trees
makes them very very difficult to
harvest and so as as the CBD era
continues to expand here and people want
to grow hundreds to thousands of acres
of hemp or CBD production you can go
through this with an industrial combine
and just mash through hundreds of acres
a day because one I mean this is a
highly fibrous plant that will just chew
out the blades of a combine and and
secondarily I mean it the morphology of
these plants just system does not lend
it to be harvested in a mechanical
fashion so we've we've looked at this
issue and developed a nominal strain
which we call CT G which stands for
cattail grade which has a high yield
expression of CBD upwards of 15% but
also grows in the same morphological
structure as a single stock as your
ex-59 and in addition to now with some
of the genetics that are available you
can have what's called autoflowering
which as the plant is growing its
vegetative matter it is also producing
the flower material that is going to be
rich in the trichomes where it has the
medicine traditionally you have your
plants near your Christmas trees that go
out you want to grow the vegetative
matter and then they they more or less
flip if you will into they stop growing
and they start producing and getting
thick in the flower material where the
medicine is well with autoflowering
varietals you're doing both processes
simultaneously so you're getting
sizeable plants that have rich
vegetative matter and very very rapidly
so whereas your ex-59 and your Christmas
trees like cherry lime will take over 20
weeks to mature out in the fields
something like cattail grave can from
the moment that a seed is planted can be
harvested within seven weeks so again
this is where science and innovation it
comes into play in this relatively new
frontier of Medicine in that if we want
to get more of this
medicine out to the masses we need to
really think about how we can solve
these these problems preemptively
because one of the biggest issues now
with with the demand of CBD is just
we're just not able to to harvest it
efficiently in time and so our our goal
here just seeking from the therapeutics
perspective is to have something like
catch a grape that can provide high
yields and be harvested very easily now
in addition to that again there is a lot
of value in the cannabinoids obviously
the the terpenes what I really believe
the magnum opus if you will here is is
looking at some of the other
classifications of molecules such as the
anthocyanins and other flavonoids and
then certainly the unknown constituents
anthocyanins are basically antioxidant
elements that give plants a very rich
deep blue purple even red pigment
they're responsible for giving
blueberries their rich pigment also very
very powerful antioxidants so cannabis
and hemp are very very rich in these
molecules and so this is something that
we're looking to explore and we also
want to look at the unknown constituents
as I mentioned previously I mean we
believe that hemp is is a is akin to
opium and the poppy that was first
characterized in the nineteen hundreds
or those hundreds of natural products
that we needed to figure out what those
things did and how they acted and I
think the same is holds true here we
have all of these wonderful analytical
instruments to characterize things in
the parks four quadrillion range and
what better use of those instruments
than to be examining this new frontier
of medicine so in terms of unknown
constituents that we've seen and here we
have again just a simple chromatogram of
the cocktail of eleven cannabinoid
standards that we have and us personally
we we characterize seventeen
cannabinoids in house on a routine basis
but what we've also found is we found
some unknown Peaks again you're looking
at you
the absorption here this is just simple
HPLC what we've seen here is we've seen
a series of unknowns here this table to
the right that we don't have cannabinoid
standards for to confirm all we can do
at this point is treat this flower
material in a variable fashion ie with
temperature heat and light to see how
these these molecules are changed so for
example unknown one here which has a
retention time of just over three
minutes on our column only appears after
after decarboxylation so it's it's not
an acidic form constituent very
similarly unknown number two increases
after decarboxylation unknown number
three is most certainly a carboxylic
acid because what we found is when we
treat plant matter that is rich in this
unknown it completely disappears after
we heated it so again this is part of
the interesting part of this new
frontier of medicine in that we have
some some analytical tools that can
provide us with insight as to what these
things may be in our case here we really
need to have great resolution power
because unfortunately or we just don't
have access to all of the the reference
materials and these these cannabinoid
standards that we would like so lastly I
just like to talk on how we plan to take
this research you know to the next level
which is going to be through a
collaboration at the University of Texas
at Arlington and we're very fortunate to
have the opportunity of working with a
good friend and colleague of mine dr.
Kevin Chuck over there who in his own
right is a phenomenal and world-renowned
analytical chemist and I apologize for
some of the the the text on this slide
here must have been a map to pc kind of
interface issue where we've got some
letters exchanged for numbers anyways
the idea here through the collaboration
with dr. shaw is to take our novel hemp
genetics and use his
very unique and highly powerful
analytical tools to discover novel
molecules in the medicine of the future
so he's very fortunate in that he has
access to what's called the shimasu
Center for advanced analytical chemistry
also known as the scat which is a 25
plus million dollar analytical facility
that has some of the most sensitive
Komatsu instrumentation so the thought
is you know why don't we take our unique
genetics let's throw them into these
unique instruments and see what we find
and then once we discover novel
molecules and characterize their
structures then we can start to do gene
expression analyses to characterize what
the physiological response of these
molecules is and so then we take it a
step further once we figured out what
these molecules are and we figure out
what these molecules can do in the body
then we can look at molecular binding
analyses and see if there's a way to
optimize that binding that may in fact
optimize the efficacy of that molecule
so then we can look at making
derivatives of these these natural
molecules in addition to altering our
cultivation for optimization so once we
know we've detected novel molecule a B
and C in strain peanut for example as we
have here in the top left then we're
going to be focusing on trying to
increase the expression of that molecule
in that strain in conjunction with
making derivatives of it so this is this
is certainly you know something that is
outside of the box or for the hem sector
however this is more or less the
approach that the pharmaceutical
industry would take in any kind of other
drug development and and we certainly
believe in in the years to come that
cannabis and hemp will certainly be in
the hands of those large-scale
multinational corporations doing this
research so I definitely see that that
being you know the wave of the future
here for the hemp industry so with that
I just want to thank you for your time
and your consideration the science of
hemp
certainly a tremendous passion of mine
as I alluded to this undoubtedly is the
future of medicine there are a number of
natural constituents that have
well-established efficacies and a number
of different pathologies and from what
we've seen this is just the tip of the
iceberg in that you know there's a
little bit of something for everyone
here and it'll be exciting to see how
this all unfolds so again my name is
Zach Holden brand was EDD therapeutics
my contact information is below and I
look forward to fielding any questions
that you may have thank you for your
time